good morning and good afternoon everyone
welcome to today's broadcast
massively parallel genome engineering
for rapid target discovery and microbes
being presented today by dr steven
federowicz a senior scientist of
computational biology at inscripta
my name is andrea i'm with labrutz and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by enscripta
for more information on our sponsor
please click on the sponsor logo on the
left side of your screen
or you can visit inscripta.com i would
like to remind everyone that this event
is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you like at any time during
the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click on the send
button
we will be answering as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
you can also use this ask a question box
to report any trouble you might have
hearing the presentation
or you can click on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window
also please notice you can share this
webinar on your personal social media
just click on the social sharing tab to
let your friends and colleagues know
about today's live event
now i'd like to introduce today's
presenter dr steven federowicz is a
bioinformatician and systems biologist
with over five years of industrial
experience in next-gen sequencing
analysis
network biology algorithm development
and machine learning
he is passionate about developing genome
scale understandings of organism
function
with high level excuse me with high
throughput experimentation and
computational techniques
dr federowvich is a senior computational
scientist in inscripto's applications
division
where he's responsible for the analysis
and interpretation of the complex data
sets generated
from the onyx digital genome engineering
platform
and with that dr federovich i'll turn it
over to you to begin
all right thank you so much for being
here with me today my name is
steve i'm a senior data scientist in the
applications group
at inscripta i'm very excited to talk
with you today
about massively parallel genome
engineering and rapid target discovery
in microbes um so to jump right in
go into the album here first thing we're
going to do is give an overview of the
honest platform
we're going to start with a brief
background because in the core
technology
uh then we're going to talk a little bit
more about the specifications and cable
mode
from there we're going to jump into a
more
expansive data discussion around genome
scale target discovery
in e coli we're going to first talk
about how we generate
over 25 000 participate edits across
seven genome scale libraries
uh we're then going to talk about how we
subject these 25 thousand edits
under pool growth elections across 11
industrial relevant
stress conditions we're going to spend
most of our time talking about the
characterization of these over 800 000
data points that come from
these relatively simple experiments and
then finally we're going to talk about
the genotype of keto head map of
response inhibitory compounds
that result from this data and
specifically we're going to
primarily focus on the toxic inhibitor
compound perforal
we'll also spend a little harder time
talking about vanillin
and importantly in this section what
we'll do is
uh we'll spend a good amount of time
really confirming the existing
literature
you'll see how in these experiments
decades of work can be recapitulated in
just a few months
beyond this platform and then finally
we'll talk about
you know after you know confirming the
existing literature we'll talk about the
discovery of hundreds of novel targets
that exist in these coordinated response
patterns and can be readily used
for strain improvement
so let me jump right in again for a
brief overview overview of the onyx
platform
uh so you understand kind of how the
data is generated and what we're talking
about
um so the background of the descripton
onyx really goes back to
this publication in 2016 um from
nature biosex our co-founder andrew
garces
showed that you could link a guide rna
with a builder molecule
and doing that in math would allow you
to
do poor multiplex commonering to
generate
thousands of individual strain variants
at once were obviously
very excited about this time of news
black faces went into inscripta
um and it was great to see that
throughout the field
um and if you're coming from the
academic side you're more familiar with
the additional publication
in the spring of 2018 there was on the
series of
wonderful publications um really
using this basic technology um make some
improvements here and there
but for the most part it was really
exciting for us to see
the community interest in generating
these types of libraries
uh it's really our goal in scripta to
make this easy
for anyone
so with that add a little bit there
so with that the key aspect of interim
technology is that
we believe that biologists need high
throughput tools to make diverse edits
genome wide
and so this graph is what we like to
think about for motivating the work
on the y-axis you have a variety of meta
types um
on the x-axis x-axis you know the number
of genomic implications that can be
accessed
so in this left-hand quadrant here
um you know across maybe 10
or 100 genomic locations you can easily
do knockouts and knock in
for protein engineering or path
engineering you can substitute in
you know 10 100 different ores you can
and plate-based workflows
and then also you can do nnk type
saturation in genesis and
achieve very high number of edits at a
very low number of low side
similarly if you're looking at uh the
lower right-hand quadrant
you can see for in cases where you have
a low rhythmic type so genomic based
ending when doing sniffs or genius by
doc house especially
yeast or plasma genitives you can act
with a large normal genomic location but
you're going to be limited by
the numbers of edits the number of
different types that it should make at
the more
locations the power of the onyx platform
is in this upper right-hand quadrant
where at a large number of genomic
locations we can make a large variety of
edit types
um phenomx platform as i'll also
introduce
is a there's an all-in-one system
software
consumables an instrument it's really
push button to enable you
to make any edits that that you can
think of
so again so current technology is
something that
happens generally in a microtiter plate
so our familiar 96 volt plate
uh and he's well in that state you might
put the um the
oligo guide rna for cut and
simultaneously put in the donor electron
nucleotide
that would be conferring edit that you
wanted
and this is this is excellent and you
can achieve high editing rates but again
you're only getting about 90 to 7 points
really the core of the instructor
technology is to instead of have a
plate-based partition
we're going to move that partition to
the individual cell
and so again that core technology that
i've showed um
early paper from garcia at all the key
innovation is to
synthesize the guide rna and the donor
with nucleotide
on an illegal nucleotide array
that would normally be used for capture
or for
other pull-down ethics by doing this you
can synthesize hundreds
um also hundreds of thousands of these
um that's what a script it does is again
we synthesize using masks
cut and paste and we also add a
trackable barcode
that can be sequenced to know
where what what cells are edited um
and what's being enriched included in
your population the data that comes from
the barcode is the primary data source
we'll talk about
today's presentation
sort of the specs of the system how does
it work
again real quick this system currently
is for e coli
and yeast um if you have uh standard
strains that we support but also any
custom strain obviously
um the strain engineers in the audience
you know we talked about rapidly
improving tolerance
um if you know the data we'll present
today and
you know you'd likely be doing that
tolerance on a custom string that maybe
already is producing
um your molecule of interest with maybe
you know a large number of heterologous
genes or
other edits already in there
um the current platform will be one edit
per cell
um the edit types are insertions
deletions or swaps
up to 60 videos so that's long enough
that you'll see today for uh
promoter insertions in e coli and you
can even do which of course you can just
do individual center if you
like the number of designs
currently support on the platforms a
hundred to a hundred thousand for
hundred to ten thousand per library um
and one of the key key metrics that
we'll talk about coming up here
um really one of the real reasons to
build this integrated microfluidic
system
and all this software is the percent
edited cell metric and i'm saying
public pool of cells comes off of the
interest instrument how many of them
have the exact edit that you want
and we'll talk about in a minute it
turns out that that's
actually hard to optimize well and it's
one of the key value
key values of the rx constant
um we'll also have design coverage so of
the ten thousand you design
making sure that you get good
representation
all right so some examples of
demonstrative types so
again i mentioned up to 60 base pair so
one thing you might want to do is
promote our rbs insertion
um uh talk about the minute you can do
things like igem promoter ladders or
other heterologous elements of drive
expression
make defined perturbations to your
system
you might want to do terminator swaps
we've demonstrated this
in other presentations doing the yeast
to
trim expression up or down
hitting a little by four and then 300
gr's um
knockouts which will stop swap codons so
in this case
uh it can be a little more robust the
normal edit type from crispr right is
making a cut and then having it be
compared to an automotive and joining um
here what we're saying is
we want to make a very precise stop code
on it at a precise race and ensure that
truncated proteins other things don't
form
and then finally a very interesting
saturation of genesis um any position
across
a protein you could introduce all
protons
to mutate that protein to every other
amino acid
all right and so ten thousand custom
designs
you think about each of these little
dots being a different design that you
make
and what comes off the machine is those
ten thousand designs are
made across population cells which the
result is millions of precisely
engineered
single cells that are going to generate
thousands of distance
and so we're making an edit what do we
mean by that uh instructor is very
particular and very proud that we
when we call when we say an edit we
needed to complete an intended edit
so that's illustrated here so uh in the
first row of the wildfire sequence
where this is the target so say you're
trying the
the wild type sequences a pac you're
trying to change it to act
um this circle will also generally make
auxiliary addicts altering the pan where
there's four spills
region um to have immunizing
effects so there's not constant
recutting but what often happens is that
this is what you want you want the
complete and intended so you designed
to change this codon
and you wanted to alter the pan site
what
often happens is that you get either
complete
unintended or partial incomplete so what
often happens is that the auxiliary
will go in to do immunizing
to prevent recutting but you're designed
that it does not donate
this is a common
feature of the you know the dynamics of
chemistry
um it's something that we've been very
careful to optimize for and
to be very clear that when we present
editing data we're only ever talking
about complete
and intended um exact sequence that you
design a new one with the genome
it's a sequence that will provide um
and again like as you can see in this
graphic on the right if you look at all
the chromosomes in these we've talked
about just
one site and this would be saying it was
90 would mean that
it wasn't that was ninety percent
cutting but ninety percent of
the cells were exact
um to make that to break down a little
bit more um
kind of the main measures of performance
we're talking about with the edit
efficiency which would be
generally talked about at a single
isolate so in onyx system
if you did look at a single isolate rs
efficiency is
greater than 95 percent and that again
includes that completely intended
exactly design
but the contrast of the literature
oftentimes in the literature
is and inefficiencies reported as
greater than 90 percent
those often include natj and nhdr um and
they don't
report uh complete unintended um you can
also get errors and synthesis process
um and that's something that we control
more correct for that are
not should not move down and not have
been treated or those
publications the next
uh most critical measure performance is
percent of edited cells
sometimes i was talking about again this
applies down to a library we're not
talking about a facebook one edit we're
talking about thousands of addicts
the percent of edited cells contain
those thousands of edits
um a typical honest value be greater
than 50 right so if you have
100 000 cells 50 000 of those cells are
going to be your complete intended edit
whereas in the literature in the best
case scenario you might get around five
percent
um reported for bluetooth
finally design preserve so if you're
looking around the genome
all the different designs that might
come up
we have optimized to ensure that on onyx
platform
you're going to get greater than 99 in
the literature
coverages that are not recorded or it
can be highly current
uh but again the data we'll be showing
will be e coli
um but we said target discovery microbes
phonics works on both e coli and yeast
and so here's just a little bit of
uh yeast performance data across a
number different library type
saturation in genesis substitutions
indels
transition combining site swaps mixed
libraries
you can see that we achieve a very
good percent of edited cells percent
complete intended edits uh
75 to you know 30
and again this would be if you have 100
000 cells 750 000 of those cells would
be the exact
edits that you wanted in your amino acid
saturation library
all right so shifting and getting closer
to the
data now to give you a background on the
platform and what it is you
understood the data i was talking about
so the general way we think about
uh off in our workflows is that pool
that itself come off the honest
instrument
um those two main workflow first
workflow is a pool
workflow where you can do selections uh
then you'll sequence those spark plugs i
talked about
and then you'll from all that data
you'll do analysis and learn
um you can go learn new insights and
move forward with your studies
uh the other workflow that i won't talk
about today i'm talking about the past
and other reference material on the
instagram
website is to take those edited cells
put them back into isolates and then do
http direct detection
um or other methods to directly test
individual lists there's a lot of
powerful aspects of both approaches
complementary and again today we're
going to talk about these pool
on sequence converges
all right after jumping into the
data here so
the problem uh common problem in
um you know the transition from a
petrochemical to about least economy is
having cost-effective feed stocks at
scale
um so many of you might be familiar with
the problem uh
the very common problem of biomass like
switch grass or the cellulose
you want to use cheap feed stock like
that to ferment valuable products
at scale but oftentimes through that
fluid acid hydrolysis or other methods
that break down that biomass
uh result in not only the fermentable
carbon sources
that you're you want your bugs to eat uh
but also a number of other
potentially inhibitory often has
inhibitory compounds
um and right once again the common
commonly happens is that
um you you know you'll start fermenting
you know
that's hydrolysis you have a low ph you
balance out that ph
realizing sodium hydroxide or the base
um
so now you have you know subjected your
your bugs to
uh hillary compound the ph problem and
now solve problem
um and so as you'll see in this study
the
undertook a massive a
campaign to determine all the targets
that would respond
geotypically due to the scientific
challenges
yeah and so since obviously many decades
of excellent work
um has resulted in the discovery of
these pathways and mechanisms to
overcome this inhibition
um but you know again you know there's a
you know perennial need
to determine the response to new
compounds
especially in our new strains and new
production conditions and then again
here today we're going to show how
decades of work can be recaptured in
just a few months
all right and so the first step
let's design and generate tonight
okay and so designer libraries here uh
we're gonna start with the hydro
promoter ladder
may be familiar to many of you and
there's 20 separate promoters here
all derived from one common motor from
ecoli
and in our libraries we're also going to
introduce gene knockouts by introducing
triple stop
uh um so the toronto letter is great
because it has a lot of relative
strength
unfortunately not in order but um you
know this promoter here the 112
is kind of the native promoter
but then going throughout this the 116
you know the 106 the 102 and the 100
all have different relative strengths
and these happen because of these minor
modifications to minus 35
and -10 tata box that enable these
promoters to drive
expression much higher in a constitutive
manner
and so we wanted to do was take these
promoters pick these motor sequence
and ultimately we're not we're not
showing here the arguments as well but
we did a full 60 base phrase
so i'm going to insert them in front of
every gene on the genome
and then also insert the gene knockouts
of position 5 and 15 of every
system of genome so what does that look
like
so if you have the polar genome here um
going around from your circle spot
um the first seven thousand nine hundred
thirty three not that's again we've made
um one knockout at position five but one
of just fifteen of every gene of the
genomes that's kind of what this looks
like going around here
uh if we then add the j23112 promoter
the weakest promoter at 1x we have
another 3676 added
one month six 106 101
100 uh for grand total 25
402 general mechanics um and so
hopefully
that becomes this this view here can
give you appreciation of the scale
really editing every gene in the genome
the type of data that we're going to be
able to get back
and then again right if you do a cross
section and look at just one gene
at each gene you would have all five
of these different promoters in front of
it and each of the two different
knockouts and that would be in seven
distinct cells each with
one of those elements
all right so that's what does that mean
it's time to take our engineered cells
off the instrument they've been designed
software
as we said and generated then we have
our cool edited cells and run our
selection experiments
what does that look like um so i
mentioned earlier we're going to look at
salt ph and biomass inhibitor tolerance
we have 25 000 edits down one two we've
pulled all these fibroids together
um we're going to focus first on further
all vanilla and hydroxyl methyl fiber
for all in centric acid
uh we're going to do biological
triplicate growth selections for each
condition we'll do 48 hour cultivations
under harvest
we also have a control condition um
it's not shown again the snow target
most genes in e coli 2676
on some more targeted future design
constraints
although many uh these are earlier
reagents and development so
um that number will go up over time we
have a 5x motor ladder the 2x knockout
ladder and against
five thousand total design um i talked a
lot about the
action of editors themselves earlier on
these libraries it's probably um
only eighteen to twenty-five percent um
for each of the promoters
um yeah and again to give you a sense of
scale
um the rant selections across all of you
and again for today's talk we're gonna
mainly just focus just on the
biomarking editors for all the known hms
instrumentation
all right so we engineered the cells
made our selections
now time to sequence that looked like
so we talked about the the setup um the
analytics chemistry
there's with a guide our name for
cutting the donor of dna molecule for
pasting that's going to confirm that
edit that we've worn
i'm going to track with barcode again
these are multiplexing to all the cells
and so and what we end up sequencing is
the sequencing barcodes
um and so showing here again like the
circular slot the collide genome
uh what's plotted down the y-axis here
is the just the
log two of the raw count to come up with
the sequence of mean particles
i'm showing here control condition um
you can see that the control condition
the knockouts
um you know you see a dispersion of
counts across the genome so each one of
these dots is that
is an is an individual cell it has an
individual edit
um in front of its um in its gene its
case knockouts
uh we look at the weak promoters now
altering the expression of averaging the
genome
and all these individual cells the
average
strength promoter strong promoter
stronger and strongest
and even now in these counts as you
click through a little bit
you can see especially going from week
to average
you start to see a general uh stretch
digital increase in accounts
along the y-axis as we dive in here to
this data we're going to talk about how
to look at this differentially how to
treat it statistically
and how to quantify that
okay so after our sequencing time to do
some analysis
learning from our data and so
the question here is how do you analyze
25000 edit
so here we take a four-step process
first thing we did was we wanted to
assess the quality and biological
reproducibility of the data
second we wanted to determine a method
of differences in the data on those
conditions how do we
look at this comparatively
and then we want to look at genome-scale
trends enrichment depletion
are there any obvious things to pop out
and then finally we want to do a
functional assessment of the enriched
depleted genes
targets to confirm existing knowledge
see if we can reveal some new findings
so what comes off um after you've done
your barcode sequencing
um is this lovely data table so in this
case right we have 25 cosmetics
so this table would have 25 000 rows uh
we might have
to show each edit here so each gene that
that is made on
and then across each of our three
biological replicates we have our
fur for all of the millennium syringes
and our five hydroxy methyl patrol
is those four inhibitory compounds
and so involved this is you know 831
thousand data points
um so how do we look at this how do we
deal with it um it looks a lot maybe
like
any other rnc account data set um we do
take some uh pages from that book and
the other crystal literature cube
on analyze data so if you plot a large
correlation matrix
um you can immediately see that there's
a lot going on
uh the first thing i draw your attention
to is the diagonals
so along the diagonals you're seeing
among for for all
among each of the one two three
biological replicates you're seeing the
the cross correlations
see this for each condition five hms
syringe and melanin control
um we're seeing for example in the
control very good biological
reproducibility
um greater than 0.954.97 controls
uh there's a puritan correlation
experiments are also equally high
um and across overall again we're seeing
greater than 0.95 correlations across
complete biological replication either
biological replicates of
this pool of 25 000 units rolling up in
selection
or sequencing those barcode counts
so in some ways it's uh it's kind of
amazing
um and so the next thing you can look at
is correlations amongst
individual inhibitors and the no
treatments for range of dispersion
so the main thing we're going to focus
on here today is control there's the fur
for all
um we'll also look a little bit about
control versus the vanillin
um and that difference of correlations
of you know 0.86
0.9 is effectively the large the larger
biological difference you're seeing
happen
given the the larger
perturbation that for calls me
so another way to look at this data is
to do a principal component analysis
so we do the principal component
analysis um
among all the data now the salt ph
ladder
uh ph gradient and each of these four
inhibitors what we see is really nice
separation
so up at the top you get the three or
four for all replicas um
coming together very cleanly top and
second principle component
and what's really nice is along the
first principle component we see both
the salt concentration gradient
and the ph gradient essentially falling
out along that component
you know really great to see not only
graphics coming together
but some of the biological significance
being shown clearly in the principle
um and so now second step here let's
take a look at some of the comparative
geno-wide responses um
so now what we're going to be plotting
on the y-axis is the log 2 of the
treatment account versus the control
count
um so we'll define that a little more
going forward but i'm in general you can
think of this just like any pull change
would do for those who
the speaker expression experiment um and
so
on the left-hand side here this is going
to be peripheral over control
control condition which would be no
inhibitor out of just glucose m9
and then over here if you vanillin look
at the controls again
one milligram focus of the milling with
uh base and nine
um and you can see a bit difference in
the response you can see that
we're showing here first for the weak um
promoters
across all the genes or on the genome um
you know things like this
where it's at this gene that
an enrichment full direction of two it's
you know what you lose consider a hit
had a strong response by putting a weak
moon in front of that gene
over here you have a massive hit almost
a four-fold response
from that for putting a beat in front of
that particular gene
but overall it's a general balance
pattern around the genome
same thing with vanillin well it gets
interesting as you start to go out
the average promoters strong promoters
stronger promoters are the strongest
promoters
um you again you start to see a little
bit of the pattern of
um you know especially even starting for
stronger stronger promoters you're
getting more
large hit um because again we're
constitutively driving expression
highest you'd expect there could be
for genes that are conferring to this
advantage they're expressed even higher
they might
confer an even larger fitness advantage
but for genes down here
you know overexpression even more uh
even more detrimental
to the cell under vanillin challenge um
and you know in the spirit of biology
was being interesting and always being
learned something new
we um looked at the knockout you can
immediately see the striking pattern
which shows up a little bit with motors
um where you know if you're looking here
along the
you know this entire megabits because
genomes this dramatic enrichment
um and you know looking a little bit
more
um you know sitting by the original
replication we know that
e coli genome is high copy number uh or
higher copy number
but i've had multiple replication forks
and log growth
we don't know why this is asymmetric a
lot of the ribosomal genes sit here
but it's just one interesting thing to
point out that you
use a system like this and look at new
biology
all kinds of interesting things pop out
all right um so after looking at the
genome scale we're going to dive in a
little bit and look at some
specific mechanisms and focus in
particular and perform
so this has been this excellent body of
work on the characterization of
peripheral tolerance
from ingram at all and really the key
mechanism
of perforal tolerance is nad nadp
starvation um so what happens and to
detoxify for
alcohol this by qhd after decades
basically reduces referral and it's
specific to nadph
since your cell has more limited amount
of nadph
and this actually causes starvation
and the cells will give lower growth
so in excellent work over a long period
of time
uh have characterized this in detail
they've knocked out
these genes by qhd the over express key
and ta
knock.yqhc did a number of really great
detailed studies to elucidate this
mechanism
and also showing you know that this
transhydrogenate here in particular
uh it's like a larger bowl of nad and
then adp
overexpression is trans hydrogens which
are between the two
can rescue the verbal polymers
okay so if we look at peripheral
response overall we're going to look at
one gene elsewhere look at that pnta
pnta trans hydrogenase that was going to
help to rescue this overall
growth defect by making more nadp
so we look at this foreign gene let's
point out here this one dot here
where it's uh increasing expression
or sorry increasing enrichment um you
can see that in ferparal
the barcode counts coming from the ngos
are high uh under control they're low
and really what we're going to be
talking about for the rest of data here
is what are these slopes and biological
responses it's really just the laws of
the
full change between the control and the
condition
and we'll get what's interesting is we
can look at these across
the library of edits of all of the seven
different edit types we made
um so each of the knockouts position
five the knockout is 15
and then the increasing promoter
strength ladder um and again
each case is for all personal control
and you're seeing
even just looking at the raw counts um
there's
you know maybe a mild effect from the
knockouts a similar effect on the weak
promoter
in many cases a very weak promoter like
he effectively
biologically equivalent to knocking out
the gene
and then under increasing promoter
strike uh you see the certificate of
effect
sort of the average motor you start to
see that there's enrichment
that this added on this gene is
conferring
overall tolerance and you sort of see
this goldilocks effect where the
the medium strength promoter uh actually
has the largest effect it seems to help
the most
and then maybe at the stronger promoters
you're actually expressing too much of
this gene
um so even though it helps the over
expression starts to cause a fitness
defect
and if we zoom out now right we were
looking at just one gene there
we zoom out uh look at all of our 25000
responses is what it looks like
we've highlighted here the black dots
are the pnta gene
so that was the slopes we were just
looking at
but you can see that those that one
detailed profile that one means
one of the 25 000 that you can get
you're going to see the broad response
patterns
overall
and so looking at this differentially
now um
and so we do the differential analysis
um we use dc2 in this case
account data type statistics um
uh if we look at the plan dominant plot
we're seeing now is
the mean cassette count plotted on the
x-axis
um the logic will change plot on the
y-axis and then we've just highlighted
less than one e to the minus third
significantly
enriched or depleted edit
and so on this access really anything
that's enriched in the population
relative to the control is considered
making the cell more resistant to
perform
anything that's depleted would mean that
we made an edit that made that cell
less and so we've highlighted here these
red dots
are all of the previously reported genes
that are known
some of the genes we're just talking
about the first was pnta if we look over
here we can see that
indeed this um transhydrogenated that
was heavily validated
um you know through through decades of
work
uh to show that it does help for
increasing peripheral tolerance
uh indeed shows up as some of the
biggest hit we're seeing multiple cases
though because
again multiple different promoters of
different constitutive strengths
all drove the same response into being
more resistant
stha was on the diagram that's another
for the other heat transaction
hydrogen e coli into this case knocking
it out it doesn't
help which is which is expected um the
second key gene is yqhd
thermal skin is invalidated but the
knockout helps resistance by
decreasing the depletion of nadph um
again shows up with one of our biggest
tips
and then a few other genes that are also
octal oxaloans
also show predictably
uh and so the exciting thing for us is
that you know there's over over
almost 3800 edits are identified to kind
of confer resistance border pollution
across the genome line of
genome-wide library and the key point is
that
these previously validated genes clearly
show up but there's many
other edits on many other gene targets
that seem to also confer a great
resistance to peripheral
and so if you're a strain engineer you
are trying to
rapidly determine all the genetic
changes that can get you to an optimum
production level
and you have optimal scale
properties you know a simple study like
this
can elucidate hundreds of targets for
you
to go off
so we just looked at what you went up
and down so normally look at this
is to look in questions so a common
way to look at clustering data at the
single spell world is to use
a umap nationality reduction followed by
http scan clustering
and by doing this across the matrix of
990 of
our of our genes of interest are highly
virtually depleted
across all six other types but looking
at that matrix
and we get these four very distinct
clusters that emerge
so if we take a second and we dive in
and look at each of these clusters um we
can see that
for this first cluster for example where
we have 222 gene for each dot is an
individual gene
we can look at a box plot of the
response of all this 222 gene
uh the striking pattern emerges where
for these 222 genes
um we see a pattern where the knockout
always generally depletes meaning it's
not helpful for verbal tolerance
whereas each of the promoters um in an
increasing manner
uh seem to help confer additional first
false calling
um so we call these tolerance confirming
college converting cluster models um in
our familiar genes we're just talking
about our transphobias kta
there's another officer with duct days
um kids in the first form of spas
show up in this cluster as jeans where
you don't want to knock it out
you want to overexpress these streams
too to help
your stream uh if you look at the
you know functional enrichment of this
excuse really interesting things the
facial transfers activity
relates to cell phone metabolism it's
like the
heavily of the nad ph heavy reactions
and so
um it can help to uh decouple that so
document doesn't help but though
expressing it can help it
to shuttle around that nadp and increase
tolerance
this transcription category is also very
interesting it's generally pointing to
here mostly uh medium global
transformation factors
kind of pointing to that pointing out
that maybe knocking out global
regulators
is actually helpful because coordinating
a complex response
which sometimes was counter to common
approach
not regulators if we jump into another
cluster here
well we see the opposite pattern so in
this cluster of 185 genes what we're
seeing is that the knockout actually
helps
um but the weak promoter or any other
promoter
generally hurts so we call these
tolerant susceptible genes which means
that
knocking them out helps but over
expressing that makes me more
susceptible
to to peripheral toxicity
uh another gene that falls in this
category for example um
makes perfect sense it's white straight
c uh in this case the next simulation
this is actually a local transfer factor
so i just told you that
the global or medium scale transcription
factors generally fall into this pattern
uh it's really interesting to see a
local transformation factor here
by qhc which specifically regulates that
y2hd gene that we talked about
um knocking that act out actually helps
and that makes perfect sense because
this is uh
an active regulator by qhd and so
knocking it out
similar to knocking out whites for hd
um and so then we also see that knocking
out things like
auxiliary carbohydrate that are all
genes that
for carbon resources not in the media
would help
and predictably knocking out some of the
nadh
machinery would not help right because
you're trying to increase that pulmonary
ph
uh let's look at the other two clusters
kind of what you expect you see that
you know your tolerance referring which
is down and up it's hard to separable
which is
popping them down um the tolerance
sensitivity that any of these 265 genes
pretty much no matter what you do the
dysregulation of them in any way
seems to help with tolerance on this
final cluster showing that
in these 318 genes anything that's
really true to them
generally hurts your protons
and so in sum total um the studies we
can directly
pitch like seven out of eight of these
heavily validated football challenge and
accreditations
um so you know everything i'm showing
here and the key act
this mechanism is heavily validated by
the excellent working room group um
you know we've re-capitulated every
study
um we identified thousands of genotype
phenotype connections that can be
readily mined to increase or decrease
the strains tolerance from peripheral
and we further show how clusters of
hundreds of these genes fall into
coordinated modules
that can be used to select targets
predictable responses
and so with that um thinking about
what's going to happen going forward so
in a forward engineering application
strain tolerance what you might do is
you might first take your top hits from
all around the genome
and really if you're looking at the
y-axis performance of your strain over
time but whatever characteristic might
be across multiple reps and editing
uh you might first run this workflow
identify all these different tips
they're going to help improve your
tolerance and then you're going to
recombine these
combinatorially uh one at a time in
multiple rounds
playing with this fitness landscape we
get an ever more tolerant and more
productive
stream
and so added scripta find out what's
coming next so i talk to you about
single edit data making one at a time
thousands of those are on the genome 25
000.
um the next steps
for releasing on the rx instrument will
be after the single edited kit will be
common to adding case
um so here's some early data again this
is the percent it's all fraction percent
edited cells
um what we're getting um two
three or even sometimes four edges per
cell across
life and these
and with that just to recap some onyx
platform supports
all aspects of the digital cycle to
first
easy design your edits portal um you can
you know make a genome mark from other
libraries knockout library
saturation regions whatever library
you'd like to make
but then the push of a button um you're
creating them on the instrument you
should do all the aviation
consumables you then test this we also
offer genotyping kits and
ease of use and now the software that
lets you upload the results
from your ngs back into our system
and finally learn to help you to cycle
the
software and solutions to help complete
the full
egtl
and again with that just to recap right
we're going to generate make this out of
the bio have this next population make
these engineered cells
um this works on cola and yeast i showed
mostly collide in today
current first document is one in it per
cell searching solutions and
substitutions
um number of designs up to ten thousand
e coli six thousand of these
uh on average thirty percent um we have
a percentage of cells
um about three to four weeks uh
manufacturing time
after you hit your design in the design
portal
in about one to three days on the
instrument
so in conclusion um creation of
libraries with up to
ten thousand um diverse genocides it's
never been easier
um so a single push of the button on
this platform can achieve what may have
taken many months or
years in the past genome scale libraries
that
systematically alter every gene in the
genome are incredibly useful to discover
new targets for any application
um you know hopefully we should be
convinced you hear that um
through just a you know a handful of
simple selection experiments
um umbrella and cost effective ngs
secrets and then just those barcodes
we can germinate generate tremendous
data really confirms all this great
biology
and introduces new things um and really
there's you know one thing that gets us
excited thinking about this
whole world of new and exciting biology
discover uh now that we can write
genotypes of you know
um instead of only rereading the ones
natural evolution has provided us always
fantastic um but you know we're
limited by the genetic diversity that we
can study and being able to write create
new genotypes of study
uh promises to open up a new era for the
bioeconomy
um and again just the you know just to
really a few
weeks from the bench um we were able to
reappreciate years of work and stress
tolerance
and also identify hundreds of new
targets for strain improvement
and thank you so much for listening
and with that i will take some questions
all right great thank you so much that
was excellent um we did have some
questions come
in we will get to those right away if
you still have a question you'd like to
ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far
left of your screen so stephen if you're
ready we will get to our first question
which is are you aiming at multiple
edits per cell
soon yes
absolutely so i know i'd come have one
flag here at the end um
um slide number 35 we talk about future
offerings in script styles with
multiplex commercial editing
um that'll be coming soon after the
release of our single edit kit
so right shown here we're showing that
we can do multiple ads per cell
um at a high cell fraction percent
edited cells
um of one two three up even up to
four in some cases for for essera vca
and in prolife
okay great next question is whether
you've considered the application of
this technology on other eukaryotic
systems
for example on cancer cells or viral
genomes
yeah absolutely so so we do obviously
i'm just talking people work in yeast
but scripta is actively working to
build tools for mammalian cell
biologists as well
and that will be coming in in the future
okay great next question
since the efficiency of editing is not
100
how will you enrich or identify the
edited population
great question great question right so
as i mentioned
the efficiency is 100 so in our case um
you know
there's a million cells 250 000 of them
um
um you know going back to this setup if
there's a million cells 250 000 of them
will be
edited so it'll be 750 000 cells that
won't be edited
um in a pooled selection
the edited cells um that compare this
advantage will out-compete the unedited
cell and so from a controlled condition
versus the challenge condition of
referrals and displays
type directional peripheral you will see
that the
um the strains that outcompeted the
others um just like an evolution
will have a stronger stronger
representation in the population
i'm going to speak of those barcodes and
the comparison will i'll show you the
ones that enriched
okay excellent um next question
do you ever see evidence of sigma 70
saturation or depletion after
inserting so many strong promoters
great question that's uh yeah very
interesting so
in our case um for uh
this current setup we are inserting um
one edit per cell um so just to go
maybe back to um right here
but we're only having one edit for sale
um in the case where we would have
multiple
you might imagine that uh multiple
strong promoters would be sucking up a
lot of that sigma 70
and causing the growth effect however
there even could be the case um
is pointing out that at certain
promoters in e coli genome
that are in very active regions perhaps
they could consume a lot of sigma 70 and
deplete it's very interesting we haven't
looked at that in detail but thanks to
the question
okay next how will this
good result extrapolate to other
bacterial species
almost for the most conservative genes
so in terms of other species again the
platform is you know set for
uh e-coli in these um and so
we do support custom springs custom
strains what we call our knees
um so if you have a production strain um
that's something that
should be compatible with the platform
in terms of other organisms that would
fall under futures
okay next you showed a strong
enrichment pattern for edits near the
origin of replication
but it seemed to be in only one
direction
why do you think it might have been
non-uniform
yeah that's a great question so pull
that back up here
so in this case we're seeing this really
strong enrichment of knockouts from
about uh three to three point nine
megabases
and the original reputation is right
around 3.3.9
um we don't know uh
we again just one of those cases where
when you're making these
thousands of you know mechanics looking
at this the first time you find new
biology
a lot of the ribosomal genes do show up
from 30 to 3.9 megabases as i mentioned
that's an area where
under log phase growth the e coli genome
has multiple replication forks and
there's higher copy number genes that
are
more important for metabolism than
essential
that is our working hypothesis
for why it might be asymmetrical
okay excellent and we have time for one
more um you showed
data for making 25 000 edits did you
actually
make all 25 000 and if so how did you
characterize that
right yes so all 25 000 notes are made
and as we mentioned we often get up to
99 coverage
meaning that they all should have been
in the population
we also showed however that in this case
we had 25
action-edited cells um
what we what we know what we see from
our data coming back
is that at the very least many many
thousands of those that have put in
and maybe the strongest way to look at
that and think about it is
when we do the g-map clustering we have
over 990 genes
where we're seeing strong responses
across multiple different edit types
so you know we know that
many many tens of thousands
okay excellent great thank you so much
um before we go i'd like to thank our
speaker one more time
and thank the audience for joining us
today we'd also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor and scripta for
underwriting today's educational webcast
the questions that we did not have time
for and those that are submitted during
the on-demand period will be addressed
by the speaker
using the contact information you
provided at the time of your
registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you by email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
so with that i thank you again for
joining and hope you have a great day
you